[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ross tucker host of the ross tucker
football podcast he works for cbs
westwood won he had the maxim game last
night between toledo and bowling green
he's gonna call the ravens dolphins game
tonight on westwood one and then he's
got bucknell and army on saturday that's
three games four days how does he do it
he's only one man he's ross tucker the
uh self-professed
meathead james van der beek always great
to see you ross thanks for joining us
dan my pleasure always good to be on i
appreciate it i'll tell you this much
dan um i love going to games when people
ask me
my favorite thing in the media the two
things i say are calling games and
filling in for you
and most of the time when people say
that they know me a lot of people
reference your show so
i am very appreciative for all the
opportunities you've given me over the
years thank you buddy uh mclovin has a
question here or a statement and then
i'll let you uh factor in or weigh in on
this mclevin go ahead
mike white is going to eventually be on
the list of the greatest undrafted
quarterbacks along with tony romo dave
craig
uh
warren moon kurt warner
someday jeff garcia jeff or at least he
has a chance to be one of those guys you
see i don't know if you ever called
western kentucky ross by the chance yeah
mike white is going to get to start
again for the jets and mclovin thinks he
could be one of the top five well he's
not going to supplant warner or moon was
are hall of famers
romo was on the outside of the hall of
fame looking and jeff garcia was pretty
good dave craig these are all really
good quarterbacks yeah i i i couldn't
find alyssa six to ten i wish i could
have oh that would help that might have
helped okay but uh
what are the jets
like they they're almost asking for
trouble here if mike white plays well
like do they get themselves in a
situation where they realize maybe the
best quarterback is not the guy they
took number two overall well first of
all i thought mclovin was going to rub
it in that dartmouth beat princeton last
week so i'm very thankful that that's
not the question i thought that was
going to be the statement he was going
to make so i'm glad we're not getting
into that yes i made a bet i said you
have to come up to the man cave and eat
tofu on me friday and he said there is
he was so upset he almost dropped off
twitter ross was like that'd be the
worst punishment known to man by the way
i did watch that game
and and princeton goes in what
undefeated and dartmouth just handed
them their lunch by the way
yeah i'm aware dan i watched my baby
well um you know listen if mclovin's
alma mater wants to lower their academic
standards and try to beat us no hey
that's up to them
okay i'm just teasing by the way
dartmouth people i'm just teasing
um but yes that was a brutal loss and i
said to him dan i'd rather take a pie to
the face than
not be able to eat meat or take my
patented road sausage away on a meat
friday
i'd rather let you guys all pie me in
the face i've heard about your road
sausage and uh
surprised you brought it up
as for mike white
i mean he looked really good against the
bengals clearly looked good on that one
drive against the colts but i'm very
curious to see how he does
when there's a little bit more of a
sample size you know the bengals were
very vanilla against him i'm not exactly
sure why and i gotta say this dan nobody
else has said this
i'm not questioning the young man's
toughness
but
we saw him throw a touchdown pass
against the colts
and then not come back in the game
you know he couldn't grip the ball
i that that's what they say and and i i
i don't know what the exact injury was
and look he's it's a golden opportunity
for him
but
i don't know man uh i mean i kind of
feel like somehow someway
you would still try to go out there but
we'll see we'll see how he does this
week against the bills defense it's
playing very very well
but i think we've seen this too many
times with the guy that comes in i mean
why isn't mclovin asking us about cooper
rush i mean cooper rush came in against
the vikings in his first start
and played very well played better than
dak did the next week so i don't know
why we're not asking that as for the
jets and having an issue i think the
issue dan
is really the way robert sala is
presenting it
you know when you hear him he's not like
he's not saying zack wilson's my guy no
matter what he's kind of he's kind of
leaving the possibility out there that
he's mike white in the game
uh by the way cam newton might be
returning to the panthers today
your thoughts on that move with sam
darnold out with the uh broken bone in
his shoulder
well i think it makes sense you know
that they're still very much in the mix
to get a playoff spot which by the way
dan we should talk about this at some
point
that extra playoff spot
in each conference it's changed
everything i mean if the saints beat the
falcons like they should have
and there's only two playoff teams two
wild card teams everybody else is at
least two games back and they might
start you know the niners might start to
play trade lance etc
but that extra spot
i mean right now the falcons have it at
four and four that extra spot
has all these teams that are three and
five three and six hey we're still in it
which is exactly what the nfl wanted it
has kept these teams in it including the
carolina panthers who they don't know
what they have in pj walker so let's see
what pj does for a game maybe two but
have cam ready because i think they
already know
that sam donald's not going to be the
guy i can't believe then
that they picked up his option in the
offseason 19 million fully guaranteed
for next year dan it never made sense
odell beckham has not decided on where
he wants to go and i'm wondering
can aaron rodgers say to the green bay
packers i want him go get him
it worked for randall cobb i mean they
had to trade for the guy
yeah i worked for him with randall cobb
the interesting thing about odell
beckham jr is i just tweeted this at
ross tucker nfl dan the longer this goes
on the more obvious it is
that he doesn't have the opportunities
he thought he was going to have you know
when you have free agency okay
those those highly sought after guys
signed the first day or two and by the
way if he doesn't sign before saturday
he misses a whole paycheck you know he
only gets you only get 18 of them now
18 paychecks for your whole salary the
whole year you don't want to skip those
i still think
he's signed somewhere
tomorrow or saturday to not skip a week
i wouldn't want to miss a week the only
other uh the only other possible
thing that's going on here
because we're all talking about him and
you're asking me about him it's two days
in a row now three years in a row
maybe his marketing people
maybe kind of like russell wilson
in the off season
have realized the value
of the dan patrick show and all of the
shows talking about you non-stop yeah
odell makes a lot of money off the field
they probably hey let it go for a couple
days let everybody keep talking about
you for a couple days just make sure
your marketing dollar is bigger
yeah i just wonder
that is he worth all of this
like no
you don't want him on your team if
you're green bay kansas city the saints
you don't want him
no i don't think so um look for the
minimum
i would give it a try
i wouldn't give him anything substantial
financially
you know i guess i believe in track
records his track record
with two different organizations now
is that
he's injured a lot
he's not very productive
doesn't like the quarterback
wants out what why is the third time
gonna be the charm and what situation is
he going to
that's so much better than cleveland
uh you had a situation with the patriots
in the panthers where brian burns got
his ankle twisted by mack jones here is
the panthers defensive end talking about
that situation with mack jones it would
be nice to have an apology
mac it would be nice to have an apology
but uh
i mean it's not gonna happen and um i
mean however the nfl handles it is on
them i would just like to play them
again
and uh i wish all my fellow dn brothers
happy hunting that's all
should mac jones apologize to brian
burns for hurting his ankle
dan things have changed a lot from when
i played
i mean
first of all i never heard a guy
apologize but even more than that
i never heard a guy ask for an apology i
mean i got spit in my face twice damn
twice
and i never say anything about it after
the game
i didn't ask for an apo i didn't tell
the media i didn't ask for an apology
wait was this on purpose this was on
perfect
somebody spent in your face on purpose
yeah twice
in 2004 um gerard warren
when we played the browns
and langston moore when we played the
bengals
and uh gerard warren
did that and then and then after the
firs that was the first play of the game
and then the next couple plays
they were pushing me after the play
so the next tv timeout
you know tv timeouts people don't
realize if you've never been to an nfl
game you're just standing out there on
the field next tv timeout i walked over
to those guys very calmly and i said hey
guys i'm tired of it i'm gonna break one
of your bleeping legs on the next play
and i walked back to the huddle
came out for the next play and alvin
mckinley was like talk talk we're good
it's over now it's over we're gonna
because they knew i was serious they
knew i was oh i wasn't gonna take it
anymore for langston moore and we've
joked about this now on social media i
was screaming he did it as he was
leaving the field so i was screaming at
marvin lewis who i knew
to put him back in the game because i
wanted to try to kill him
you know we didn't
you know we don't we don't ask for we
don't ask for apologies
we demand forgiveness by taking that's
what's great about football you can take
it out on them you can inflict pain and
punishment on them
why would a guy spit in your face on the
first play of the game
well so for gerard warren it's because
we scrimmaged them that year we had an
inner scrimmage during training camp i
think
and oh i know that and i think this is
why
um and
i
i threw him down the ground and then
kind of speared him
and he didn't really like that that's
the same game dan that we're beating
them so bad okay
we're up by like three touchdowns late
in the game
i'm blocking gerrard
instead of trying to make the tackle he
goes like this real quick and puts my
arm in a armbar
and he said
i'm gonna break
your mother effin arm
and i was like joe no no no please don't
draw no
i i i thought he was serious like he had
me like you know in like one of those
ufc like yeah i'm gonna break your arm
things i was like no george no he didn't
even try to make the tackle damn he just
goes i'ma break your mother effin arm
what the hell happened on monday night
in the with the taunting call with tony
corenti
uh i thought it was amazing one of my
favorite moments the nfl season i've
never seen an official
draw the foul
like like
like he's lebron james trying to get the
n1 i mean that was amazing and then my
favorite dan did you see him
hold his hand in the air
like me draining a three in high school
basketball and just like hanging in the
air after he threw the flag
tony corente tony corente literally
taunted cassius marsh while throwing a
taunting penalty on him
i thought it was amazing um i will say
this and i might write about this in my
next column
i am actually one of the only people
that's supportive
of the tawning rule now i didn't think
what cassius marsh did
deserve to be flagged
but dan you know i've got gobig
recruiting a high school athletic
business you you should see then
junior high football you should see
seven on seven football these kids will
catch a touchdown
you know in the end zone over in seven
on step no helmets or anything
and they'll get right up in their face
and be like
like and stare them down
that's another thing that's different
from when i played i would just punch
the kid right in the face no hesitation
just
boom like i don't that that is why what
tom once said that's why they're trying
to get rid of it because the younger
kids
they see that they see them getting each
other's face and then that's what they
do they do it seven on seven junior i've
seen it pop warner
it's disgusting it's disrespectful and
they mimic what they see the nfl guys do
it's unnecessary
didn't have a problem with
you know if taunting was called on the
play it was just late in the call and
you waited until the player make you
know you make contact with the player
and then you pull the flag that's the
problem i had with this you want to call
taunting call taunting because the
letter of the rule it would constitute
throwing the flag you can't wait till
you make contact with somebody and then
you call the taunting penalty on
somebody while you taunt the person you
just called taunting on you know what
dan it it reminded me of like an nba ref
sometimes or college basketball when
they make it about them yeah like they
think it's about them it's it's not
about you
i would say this year out of let's say
there's been 30 taunting flags
i'd say about 15
maybe 20 i agreed with
5 to 10 i didn't but now dan it's the
rule
it's like the covet rules like
it's the rule so anybody that gets it
now
that's on you it's clear what the rules
are it's clear what they're doing so you
can keep complaining about it or you can
just not do it so you don't hurt your
team
uh have fun tonight safe travels as
always and uh thanks for joining us
buddy
always thank you dan all right the uh
self-titled meathead james van der beek